shocking body camera video shows Ohio
police officers repeatedly punch a
suspect in the face leaving him bloody
and screaming
[Music]
[Applause]
your kid's okay
no
search him the incident happened on July
1st in Akron Ohio when officers there
ran a registration check on a vehicle
with a temporary tag they found the
plate was expired they also found active
warrants linked to the driver 31 year
old Jordan Ellie senior body camera
video shows officers approach Ellie
seconds before he's pulled to the ground
what's up man all right hey come here
Ellie can be heard repeating please sir
as officers call for him to get to the
ground
he then asks officers to stop saying his
son is in the car nearby but officers
refuse to stop and seconds later video
captures them punch Ellie in the face
please don't do this to me
okay okay
the struggle then continues as the body
cam is partially obstructed
[Laughter]
Ellie again calls for officers to stop
saying he can't breathe
behind your back do it now stop
resisting let go of your hand let go of
your hands I got a hand here okay
here
put your hand behind your back
dude
yeah
stop it dude
[Music]
I'm sorry
please oh sure I got it
I just want to see this
stop I just want to say that one
eventually Ali asks officers if he can
be taken to the hospital when they
refuse he says quote just kill me
officer
stay right here
[Applause]
so you got 32 supervisors
oh my God
yeah
yeah shut up okay
just kill me no during this time Ellie
can be seen with blood covering his face
no stop no no no no no
no stay right here no no no no no no no
no
[Music]
[Applause]
your kid's okay
search him go ahead stand up man
stand up stand up
stand up
oh
Jordan stand up dude they're gonna lift
up on your arms beat your feet up under
you
all right you want to stay down there
additional officers approach asking
whether Ellie has been searched
him I just did a quick patch
take a couple steps back for me
okay roll over
okay okay
car hasn't been searched
he's got a bunch of boards
if you uh still have to handle the
channel held you could release it and uh
slow anybody else down
minutes after Ali first told officers
his son was in the vehicle nearby
officers addressed that the child is in
the car
bro
we'll start at 32 foreign
what is it
[Music]
officers then explained that Ellie's tag
is expired and there are warrants out
for his arrest Ali maintains he wasn't
trying to fight that well your tags
expired man you got a bunch of warrants
so if you just listen to us know this
way
that's ridiculous officials later found
a baggie inside Ellie's vehicle that
tested positive for fentanyl body camera
video captures officers ask Ali whether
he's swallowed any drugs
what a concept that is
I didn't do nothing
so listen man it's all over with all
right let's have you take a stand up
okay all right
let's go it's all right swing your feet
under here get up
let's get your shoes back on
outside of your mouth
come on stand up come on dude
you didn't swallow any drugs did you oh
sir bro
officials then lead Ali into a squad car
where they tell him an ambulance is
nearby
yeah
all right come on
Ambrose is coming I'll check you out
soon yeah
[Applause]
usually almost
Ally was later charged with resisting
arrest obstruction of official business
and felony drug abuse his son was later
released to a family member
following Ellie's arrest the Akron
Police Department released a statement
saying a use of force investigation is
now underway to determine whether those
responding officers acted appropriately
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie